On Saturday, William's
parents gave birth to twins
and named them
Nadia and Vanessa.
When they were first born,
Nadia weighed 7.27 pounds
and was 21.5 inches tall, and
Vanessa weighed 8.34 pounds.
How much did the
babies weigh in total?
So they tell us Nadia weighed
7.27 and Vanessa weighed 8.34.
We have to add those up.
And really, they
just gave us this.
The length of Nadia at birth
really is a distraction,
just so that we just
don't mindlessly
add any numbers we see.
So this is really
unnecessary information
just to distract us.
So we need to add Nadia's
birth weight plus Vanessa's.
So it's 7.27.
So 7.27 plus 8.34.
And it's always important
that we line up the decimal.
And I'd like to do
the decimal first.
So it's 8.34.
And we'll just add these two up.
So 7 plus 4, and this is
really 7/100 plus 4/100
is 11/100, which is the same
thing as 1/100 and 1/10.
1/10 plus 2/10
plus 3/10 is 6/10.
We've got our decimal
sign right over there.
And then 7 plus 8 is
15, or you could even
say it's five 1's and one 10.
And we're done.
They weighed 15.61
pounds in total.